a surge in covert 19 cases driven by the
omicron variant has been disrupting
holiday travel plans all across the
world thousands of flights have been
cancelled globally because of the impact
of the coronavirus on airline employees
and on passengers despite this people
are trying their best to maintain the
christmas spirit
it was the night before christmas
but instead of the usual last minute
christmas rush the streets here in
london have fallen silent
the uk broke their record of covert
cases for the third day in a row
recording about
122 000 infections
numbers have climbed so high that some
estimates predict one in ten londoners
have the infection
the surge in cases has dampened the
christmas cheer and left many industries
struggling with staff shortages as sick
workers are forced to isolate
it's a problem that has hit airlines
particularly hard flights around the
world had to be cancelled on christmas
eve adding another layer of stress to
people's already precarious holiday
plans
we were really concerned last night when
i saw on the news that they had
cancelled 100 flights and i'm like oh my
god we won't be able to get home
but luckily we kept checking the flight
status checking the flight status got
here and everything was fine so we were
really grateful for that
in spain you don't have to be traveling
far to face disruptions to everyday life
just stepping outside your front door
now means having to wear a mask
the prime minister announced the
decision after two consecutive records
in daily cases
it's come as an unwelcome surprise to
many
when we got off the train and i saw
everyone wearing their mask i remembered
that it was the first day of the mandate
and i thought what a drag again with the
mask it's a bit suffocating a bit
claustrophobic i'm not very happy
though it may not be the covert free
christmas that so many had hoped for
people are doing their best to make sure
some of the festive spirit remains
let's get more from peter chen hong he's
a professor of medicine at the
university of california in san
francisco professor welcome back to dw
it's nice to see you
omicron is turning out to be far more
infectious what is the knock-on effect
in terms of the sheer scale can we
expect that everyone
across the world perhaps is going to
come in contact and not just come in
contact but actually contract this virus
in the coming weeks and months
well that's what some people are
thinking rebecca that it's so
transmissible up to four times as much
as delta that it will be hard to escape
but nevertheless i think we could try to
mitigate damage and we're most worried
about unvaccinated folks and folks with
co-morbid conditions it's still going to
result in a lot of hospitalizations even
though it's probably less
you know severe uh to the general person
as delta was
you mentioned vaccine vaccines there but
studies uh just released in the last few
days show that vaccines are to be much
less efficient than previous variants
with one relatively large study in the
uk suggesting even with a booster you're
only really protected for around two
months
what do you say to that what does that
mean for people
well it all depends what our goal post
is if your goal post is prevention in of
infection then sure you can look at the
vaccines and say
two doses you know 20 30
uh a booster probably doesn't give you
much more but and not for that long but
if you look at the outcome of serious
disease hospitalization and death uh the
vaccines are really spectacular that and
as an infectious disease doctor if you
told me i had a choice between just
preventing infection or serious disease
i'll choose serious disease any time
absolutely
does that mean then that we're going to
be having booster shots
every couple of months
well again it comes back to what our
goal in society is so i can give you all
this science and tell you that this uh
vaccine or booster might only last
10 weeks before it wanes in efficacy
against infection but if we re-evaluate
and think that we were thinking mainly
of hospital capacity
and the ability of hospitals to you know
take care of sick people then maybe
after uh at some point we'd be able to
accept that you know with three doses
maybe uh we'll be good enough with
prevention of people going to the icu
dying and we'll accept a certain amount
of disease in the in society
i'm sure everyone certainly hopes so
professor peter ching hong in san
francisco thanks very much for your time
merry christmas
merry christmas rebecca thank you
well many of europe's hospitals are once
again being stretched to their limits
and staff are more burnt out than ever
despite that they're still trying to
bring some joy to patients spending
christmas on the wards dw's christine
mundwa reports from liege
tis the season but much of the jolly has
gone
there are more masks than santa hats
another year another variant another
covert christmas
at this hospital in the belgian city of
liege vaccines mean it's better this
time around but they're not sure how
long that will last
this time last year this hospital was
overwhelmed with covert 19 patients it
got so bad some of the icu patients had
to be airlifted to neighboring germany
the situation is under control for now
but the staff here are bracing for
omicron
this is the covert ward and staff here
are hoping for the best but they're
preparing for the worst and keeping a
nervous eye on omicron infection numbers
we are hoping that it won't be too
strong because we know also that we
don't have
all the stuff we would need if it was
very very big and we will do our best
health workers have had a grueling
couple of years
the hospital psychologist says the
uncertainty is making it difficult to
cope
i don't see that people the nurses or
doctors are afraid
they're more anxious
that this might go on forever
that this repetition just won't stop
because in the end one variant chases
the last
and it comes in waves
which is very
exhausting tired as they are
nursing staff will as they always do try
to lift the spirits of those in hospital
this christmas
but that's particularly tricky with
covet patients they're isolated and
can't have visitors but there will be a
special surprise on christmas morning
we have some
kids who are writing some court
every year but since i'm here since
years and years they're writing little
cards for people and the morning of
christmas we put the cottons uh
on the
platoon the meal
with the meal and they get it and they
have a little cat saying hello i think
about you
staff have created an oasis of calm and
care here
but they know it probably won't last
long
outside infections are spreading fast